je revenais chez moi et j'ai l'habitude
de longer les chats que les chansons
sombre et j'ai vu une énorme dôme
lumineux orange
un soir où est ce qu on est passé en
voiture puis on a vraiment été
impressionné de la grosseur que savait
l'ampleur que ça va
je me suis arrêté sur le mouvement de la
rogers se pencher pour prendre en photo
dans l'impression de marcher sur la
planète mars
c'est vraiment impressionnant la lumière
est perceptible à des centaines de
kilomètres à la ronde pour l'oeil humain
fait on lie animal puis pour les
végétaux d'eau pour ça assurément si
c'est très perceptible pour nous il ya
quelque chose c'est parti
depuis quelques années il ya des
lumières puissante qui apparaissent dans
le ciel de certaines campagnes des
aurores boréales artificielle qui
réapparaissent toujours au même endroit
les serres de cannabis se sont
multipliés au pays depuis la
légalisation en 2018 puis ça vaut bien
pour les serres maraîchères en ce moment
pour accroître notre autonomie
alimentaire le gouvernement du québec a
récemment dévoilé une stratégie qui vise
à doubler la superficie desserts de
fruits et légumes d'ici 2025 pour les
amateurs de produits le cause d'une
brillante solution est justement un peu
trop brillante pour les yeux de certains
on y va
les scientifiques qui étudient la
pollution lumineuse savent que la
lumière nocturne et peut nuire à la
santé humaine et même perturbé les
écosystèmes
je veux savoir si on prend des risques
en illuminant la nuit ici à des
solutions pour qu'on puisse profiter des
avantages des stars tout en préservant
l'obscurité 11,3 depuis que les serres
ont transformé la production de tomates
en cannabis là on a des problèmes de
luminosité et de floraison
on ne parlait à une dizaine de résidents
de mirabel qui nous ont tous dit la même
chose et en a certains qui ont même
lancé une pétition qui a été signée par
plus de 1500 personnes
le président est en campagne si la
tranquillité c'est la nature
[Musique]
canopy grotte l'entreprise qui gère les
serres de cannabis à mirabel nous a
répondu avoir installer des rideaux
opaques sur le court des desserts mais
on voit il ya quand même la lumière qui
se dégage faire le ciel était très
visible sur tous les soirs nuageux comme
ce soir est ce que ça peut être nocif
ya pas beaucoup de scientifiques qui
travaillent sur la pollution lumineuse
au québec mais j'en ai trouvé un dans un
sombre village au bout d'une sonde rue
puis je pense pas que ce soit un hasard
je l'astrophysicienne youth astronomes
amateurs c'est mon atelier
en fait mon atelier bureau ça c'est une
cameron par une photo du site
c'est un système d'observation qui voit
dans un ballon stratosphérique des
mouches astronomes à la base c'était
plus au ciel étoilé qui m'intéressait
maintenant au fil du temps je me suis
rendu compte que le côté environnemental
me sentais aussi le était peut-être là
je la pollution lumineuse c'est de la
lumière artificielle et mise donc par
par les humains qui va se propager dans
l'environnement avec une intensité trop
fort avec une couleur inadéquate et qui
va perturber l'environnement naturel au
niveau de la santé humaine on s'est
d'abord que les cycles plusieurs cycles
biologiques hormonaux sont contrôlés par
la lumière lorsqu'il ya de la lumière
qui comporte une partie de lumière 2,3
bandante par rapport ce que la nature
nous donne normalement on arrive à
déséquilibrer apparemment les cycles
hormonaux et donc développer des
maladies notamment des cancers
hormono-dépendants et aussi des
hypothèses hawks ont exploré au niveau
de l'obésité différentes autres maladies
les travaux de martin oublier ont montré
une corrélation entre l'incidence des
cancers du sein de la prostate et du
côlon en milieu urbain
chez les personnes qui ont une source de
lumière blanche tout près de leur maison
mais comme pour le diabète ou l'obésité
c'est vraiment difficile d'établir un
lien de cause à effet entre la pollution
lumineuse et ces conditions il ya
plusieurs études qui se sont penchés sur
la lumière blanche parce qu'elle
contient une bonne part de lumière bleue
celle qui peut influencer nos cycles
hormonaux lessard elles sont souvent
équipés de lampes au sodium
même si la lumière qu'ils émettent et
orangé et conseille quand même entre 5
et 10% plus
ce qu'on ne sait pas à ce moment là
c'est quel niveau de lumière ça prend
pour perturber la santé des gens la
prolifération de ce type de sources là
comme dessert oui ça m'inquiète beaucoup
je dois dire que c'est pas seul souci
que j'ai pas ce qu'il y à toutes les
lumières partout heureusement que la
plupart des humains vivent sous un
environnement pollué au niveau pollution
il on parle de 90 % des gens au niveau
des pays développés au niveau de la
planète et une alimentation de leurs
deux minimalement 2 4% par année donc
c'est énorme
les endroits sombres ou des humains
habitent sont de plus en plus rare qu'un
nouveau point qui est apparue récemment
sur les images satellite de recensement
des ondes lumineuses celui des serres
toundra les deux premières phases en
opération s'étendre sur 19 hectares et
il y en a une troisième qui va être en
construction dès l'été 2021 on vole en
ce moment juste à côté de ça retombera
arriver à ses fins
8h30
[Musique]
la lumière est vraiment est consciente
on la voit de loin mais le des proches
c'est encore plus forts évidemment qu'il
se serait fait dans les nuages ça fait
comme un deux minutes les attendra sans
complexe qu'ils étaient mis à
l'opération et environ 5 1 en cinq ans
que de nous les plus gros producteurs de
concombres ce qui est bien nous on
récupère tout look on utilise pour
arroser nos plans c'est l'eau de la
pluie la neige qui fond c'est tous des
petits trucs comme ça qu'on fait pour
l'environnement n'utilise pas ce sirop
fonds utilise des bars clubs de cartons
malgré des mesures écoresponsables très
sophistiqué lessard toundra font pas
juste des heureux en décembre 2020 simon
gobeil un citoyen la région exprime ses
inquiétudes sur facebook et cette
publication a fait beaucoup réagir pense
que eu tout près de 400 partage de mon
poste jamais vécu ça et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de commentaires au
dessus de 200 commentaires pour montrer
des exemples de photos de chez eux de
caisse qui voit puis de qu'est ce qu'ils
ressentent
de l'autre côté du lac
de 80 km dans le parc de chimie bien
monde métabetchouane de saint-gédéon les
serres sont perceptibles partout il faut
dire qu'au moment où simon a fait sa
publication les stars faisaient des
tests de nuit sans les écrans qui
servent normalement à bloquer la lumière
depuis leurs écrans sont en fonction
mais on a contacté beaucoup de personnes
la région de saint félicien et sans
vouloir le dire à la caméra il y en a
plusieurs qui nous ont confié que le
problème n'était pas réglé
souvent les gens qui ont peu parlé
ondimba nous on s'est installé ici
justement parce que c'est tranquille des
beaux ciels ccc sombres la nuit
pis le bain ça arrive qu'ils ont un peu
l'impression d'être en ville même
actuellement tels que tels que les
écrans sont installés aux présentes
également jeudi le renvoi
lors de notre visite leur halo était
saisissant c'est sûr que la météo était
idéale pour l'observer et juste à côté
dessert les émanations de l' usine de
produits forestiers résolu créer un
écran qui diffuse la lumière
il reste que cultiver les concombres à
l'année
ça implique 19 heures d'éclairage par
jour quand les jours sont les plus
courts puis 18 heures quand les joueurs
recommencent à allonger et ainsi de
suite
moi ça fait à peu près 20 ans quand on
habite ici on s'attendait pas
nécessairement à vivre autant de
luminosité dont on observe quand même de
façon quotidienne régulière
j'ai une inquiétude par rapport à la
biodiversité puis par rapport à la faune
et à la flore est ce que ça peut créer
un incident sur les animaux sur ce qu'on
apprécie aussi devoir à tout les jour au
quotidien
est-ce qu'on va perdre son os qui va
avoir une influence négative ce soit que
ça déséquilibre l'environnement ça c'est
certain
en fait sur le vivant la pollution nous
en un pack très marqué très bien
documenté beaucoup plus que pour la
santé humaine paradoxalement on sait que
sur certaines espèces
seul un effet dévastateur je pense aux
oiseaux migrateurs
lorsqu'il arrive autour des grandes
villes on se met à tourner souvent puis
vont mourir d'épuisement
mais encore plus important que si riche
passons aux insectes
toutes les autres espèces dépend des
insectes on sait maintenant qui à peu
près 150 insectes qui vont mourir à
chaque nuit pour chaque lampadaire parce
que les insectes sont attirés par la
lumière et encore une fois le ton des
oiseaux migrateurs
ils vont s'épuiser à force de tourner
pour une ville qui contient des
centaines de milliers de lambada
récemment traître prévu les végétaux
aussi peuvent être affectés par la
lumière nocturne qui peut perturber leur
germination par exemple
avez vous déjà remarqué qu'à l'automne
les tenues qui se trouve près d'un
lampadaire prennent des couleurs et
perdent leurs feuilles
un peu plus tard que les autres la
baisse de luminosité à la fin des pis
pour les arbres
si le signal qui leur indique de
commencer à faire des réserves pour
affronter l'hiver les scientifiques
craignent que le froid n'arrive
alors que certaines plantes sont pas
tout à fait prête en milieu aquatique
les fameuses cyanobactéries sont
visibles pour les coupes d'eau peuvent
bénéficier d'un peu plus de lumière
il ya des études qui ont même montré que
la période de ponte de certains poissons
pouvait être décalée à cause la lumière
artificielle qu'on parle de plantes ou
d'animaux
on connaît pas encore les effets à long
terme la pollution lumineuse sont les
écosystèmes la lumière se propage à très
grande distance particulièrement la
campagne en fait parce que un des
obstacles à la lumière sur la présence
d'édifices d'arbres en fait c'est
l'érosion lumineuse compte entre une fin
où l'on crée un vide dans
l'environnement pour les animaux c'est
plus une option pour huit passés par là
je terminerai en disant qu'il ya à peu
près plus de 60 % des espèces animales
qui sont nocturnes donc que c'est leur
environnement naturel
ils ont besoin de noir ça
[Musique]
la plupart des personnes à qui on ne
parlait ont tenu à préciser qu'ils n'ont
rien contre les salles mais elle se
demande s'il existe des solutions et s
questionne sur ce qui fait la richesse
de la région des dix amants de la nature
comme beaucoup de gens ici au lac saint
jean
mais comme beaucoup de gens partout au
québec le mais ici c'est un immense
terrain de jeu où les gens sont des
pêcheurs des chasseurs s'il fondamentaux
nargis on ne la connaît les bons c'est
sa part tout et puis c'est beau puis
c'est ça c'est ça aussi l'environnement
c'est pas juste l'impact nécessairement
que la lumière va avoir sur directement
sur des écosystèmes ou sur des
organismes vivants mais aussi sur ce
qu'on voit au quotidien puis
l'environnement dans lequel on vit
[Musique]
dans le cas des serres cette tension
entre la volonté de préserver les
écosystèmes et la vitalité des projets
industriels et peut être contournée
relativement facilement notamment grâce
à des technologies comme des écrans au
tac noir ont regardé plat nouvelle salle
à forte aux amandes et on va mettre son
label black screen pour vraiment coupé
81 18 99% lumière c'est quand même
beaucoup plus dispendieux
je pense pas c'est tout le monde qui
vont et qui vont utiliser cette énergie
est présentement parce que c'est plus
dispendieux ça vous coûte plus cher ah
oui très beaucoup beaucoup au bout de la
ligne
comme nous prions fait que réfléter le
cycle du soleil en plein été on peut
produire au soleil ferme toile mais
c'est la même mais ma femme nous c'est
comme s'ils étaient à l'année longue
quoi donc une solution existe
là on est de retour à montréal si la
ville où se trouve la plus grosse heure
sur toi en milieu urbain au monde
ça c'est la dernière installation des
fermes lufa et elle est équipée de
rideau au tac
ce qui fait qu'on voit pas grand chose
puis en plus ils nous ont dit que ça
conserver une certaine partie de la
chaleur à l'intérieur
ailleurs au pays yo des municipalités
qui ont décidé de s'attaquer aux
problèmes avec leur carnet de
contraventions
c'est le cas de kingsville dans le comté
d'essex en ontario labeur ya beaucoup de
serre et les entreprises qui illumine la
nuit s'exposent à des amendes qui
peuvent monter jusqu'à 50 mille dollars
dans le plan de croissance dessert lancé
par le ministère de l'agriculture du
québec il ya un volet environnemental
important
on souhaite que les serres et accès au
réseau d'hydro-québec plus facilement et
à des tarifs avantageux
et ça ça va réduire leur empreinte
carbone parce que la plupart d'entre
elles ont recours aux combustibles
fossiles comme source d'énergie
donc on nous demandait au ministère de
l'agriculture s'ils prévoyaient un cadre
des recommandations par rapport à la
pollution lumineuse
ils nous ont répondu que l'implantation
harmonieuse décès relevés des instances
municipales
alors on a posé des questions à l'union
des municipalités du québec qui nous ont
dit que c'était pas un enjeu qui était
discuté actuellement au sein de leurs
membres peu plus que c'est un sujet
chaud chez les producteurs en serre du
québec
aucun on le jour on pollue des rivières
ou peu importe ce qu'on va faire
polluent l'atmosphère
je pense la plupart des gens on s'est
entendus auxerre aucun rebond semble
donc à ce moment là pour moi c'est une
évidence que si on veut protéger
l'environnement il faut protéger la nuit
ça nous a été imposée et et c'est comme
quand ton voisin vient mettre une
clôture sur sa ligne le tir et puis
quitte en parle paul bert et rapidement
par les listes ordinaires que ce soit de
rosanne reaume aux nouvelles ou des
serres de cannabis ont de quoi dire
qu'on s'en tient aux propos moule qu'on
se mobilise d'apporter des solutions
pour que tout le monde ensemble
collectivement on peut sortir du parti
je pense que dans une société
tout le monde doit s'exprimer qui va
toujours avoir des mécontents ne sont
pas deux trois mois par année pour avoir
des légumes frais à l'année pour avoir
des légumes dans le fond de qualité je
pense comment il faut décider bon mais
est-ce qu'on fait un sacrifice ou non
sur certaines choses
[Musique]